when you made this in 1978 I like this
idea of that you had to figure out how
to pace yourself
filming the scenes you have to gauge
where you were I was my first job as an
actress really and certainly my first
large role and you know in a horror
movie there's a level of intensity that
builds and after a certain thing happens
basically it's your Full Tilt boogie
toward the end of the movie you know
you're just really really intensely
afraid but there's a lead-up there's a
gentle time and then there's questioning
so what I did and I think I was quite
smart to figure this out at 19 nobody
did it I numbered my script so that I
would know at what level I was as the
script progressed so that then when you
shoot the thing out of order and they go
okay we're gonna shoot this scene now I
would know it's sort of like a scarer
meter if you will yes you know where 10
is the Lensbaby one is the sort of high
school girl in her classroom a 3 would
be the patented Jamie Lee Curtis
incredulous who are you look which is
this please can I tell you something
about 11:00 yeah so my husband is
Christopher Guest who was in this is
spinal tap and he's Nigel and Nigel's
amp goes to 11 he would be so mortified
that I just like did a bad cockney
accent so good at it but I Drive a Tesla
I'm sorry you know and when I was being
shown the car by the technician the guy
says to me Chris is in the car he says
to me well turn up the air-conditioning
and I'm like ok and I'm turning up the
air-conditioning goes no keep going I'm
like okay I'm going he says no keep
going and the air conditionings going on
and the air conditioning goes to 11
and the volume control in the audio goes
to 11 it's because Elon Musk was a big
fan of spinal tap and so in a Tesla the
air heat goes to 11
[Applause]
[Music]
you